♪♪
♪ Blow Your Mind ♪
-Questlove!
Do you want to explain
how the game works?
-Of course, Jimmy.
In this game,
I will read each of you
a mind-blowing fact.
And you must decide
if that fact is true or false.
If you choose wrong,
we will blow your mind.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You will be blasted in the face
from the tube in front of you.
Make the right choice,
and your opponent
gets their mind blown.
-Okay, I gotcha.
[ Clears throat ]
-The first fact is for Dwayne.
-Yeah.
-True or false...
-False.
-Wait, wait, wait. Hold on.
You know that?
You think there's -- No,
that's got to be false, right?
-It's false.
-Wait, but -- Wait.
I don't want to be --
I don't want my mind blown.
-Yes, you do.
-Are you sure?
I am absolutely positive.
-All right.
He's locking it in.
-I remember this.
-Okay.
-The answer may surprise you.
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
-[ Laughs ]
-It's true!
Can we see that again
in slow motion?
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
-Nice.
-There are more stars --
-The next fact
is for you, Jimmy.
-Okay, yeah, yeah.
If laid out end to end...
-[ Groans ]
-Truth or a lie?
-[ Laughs ]
No, you could be acting
like it's so obvious.
-Ahh!
-I know, 'cause I think
that it's obvious.
I think I've heard this,
that, yes, it is, the small --
Oh, wait.
Or is it the large intestine?
-Yeah.
-The small intestine.
-I think this is
a trick question.
First of all,
I've never looked cooler.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Uh, I think I would say
that is -- that is, uh, true.
It's longer
than a football field.
-Is he correct?
-The answer might --
-The answer may surprise you.
-Yeah. There.
Yes.
-Ahh.
-That is a lie.
Let's see that mind blowing
again in slow motion.
-Yeah!
-What the heck was that?!
-Lettuce in the mouth!
-Wait. You didn't get lettuce!
Why do I get --
You got, like, conf--
You got, like, Fruity Pebbles!
You got Fruity Pebbles.
I got some old salad.
-I got cotton.
-What the heck was that?
-There's bacteria on that salad.
-Dwayne.
-Oh, my God!
-Yes.
-You're up next.
-All right.
-Fact or fiction?
Truth or false?
-This is a joke.
Look how big my hand is.
[ Laughter ]
-That is completely,
unequivocally false.
-Yeah, I agree.
-The answer --
-Answer may surprise you, yeah.
-Yes. The answer
may surprise you.
-Ohh.
-It's true. Can we see that
again in slow motion, please?
-What'd you get in that?
-That was harder.
-That was hail.
You got hit with hail.
Oh, hail, no!
You got hailed.
-I got hail no.
-All right.
-This next fact is for Jimmy.
-Wait. Wait.
-Does that -- Wait.
So there's only two escalators
in the state of Wyoming?
-Yeah, apparently.
-Oh, okay.
-You want to get another --
-No, I'm good, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Truth or a lie?
-[ Imitating flushing ]
I'm --
Toilet, not urinals, right?
Toilets.
-Toilet.
-[ Imitating flushing ]
Was that E-flat?
♪ You give me that note,
Is that an E-flat? ♪
♪ That's E-flat, yes, it is ♪
-[ Imitating flushing ]
I think, if so,
that's a total coincidence.
I will say
that is absolutely false.
-All right.
-Is he correct?
-Just -- Ohh!
-Yeah! [ Laughs ]
-You were supposed to say --
You were supposed to say,
"The answer may surprise you."
-Nah. Let's see that mind
blowing again in slow motion.
-You're supposed to say,
"The answer may surpr--"
What was that?
-Yeah!
-I don't know what that was.
It was like a Ziploc bag
of kidneys or something.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Thunder crashes ]
-Excuse me.
-Oh, yeah. Oh. E-flat.
-That sound means it's time
for the final question.
It's a simple
yes-or-no question.
And it comes with a twist.
If you answer incorrectly,
both of your minds
will be blown.
-Dwayne.
-Okay.
-The question goes to you.
-Oh, gosh!
-[ Laughs ]
I know.
I better do the same thing.
-Just do the same --
We're not gonna get this right.
-All right. 'Cause this
is extremely debatable.
-Yeah, I know.
I know. It is. Yeah.
-My answer --
is a hot dog a sandwich?
Yes, it is a sandwich.
[ Audience booing ]
-Oh, boo!
-Are you sure?
[ Laughter ]
-A hot dog is a sandwich.
It's got meat and two --
and two pieces of bread!
-Look at you yelling that.
Or debating is -- All right.
-Is the answer correct?
[ Laughter ]
-You are wrong.
A hot dog is not a sandwich.
Let's see the shock again
in slow motion.
-There you go. Look at this.
Blam! Right there.
Ooh.
Got a little mustache there.
I had, like, a --
"Time to make the doughnuts."
-You look so cool.
-Thank you. You too.
Dwayne Johnson
is the winner, everybody!
Come on! The champ!
Check him out hosting "Saturday
Night Live" this weekend.
Ellie Kemper
joins us after the break.
Stick around, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪